-Well, you guys,
it was a beautiful day
here in New York,
with temperatures
hitting 70 degrees.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was great.
New Yorkers were outside
lathering themselves
with sunscreen and Purell.
It was amazing.
[ Light laughter ]
But today was nice.
But I can't wait for tomorro
when everyone shows up
with a weird face-mask tan
[ Laughter ]
That's right, these are fu
times to do a show right now
They really are.
Just so everyone knows,
in the event someone
in the audience lightly coughs
the emergency exits
are here, here, and here.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No problem.
But I'm excited about this
Alex Rodriguez
is my guest tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
A-Rod -- A-Rod is gonna previe
the new baseball season,
and it sounds like
it's gonna be crazy.
[ Audience "Whoos" ]
Instead of signs,
the Houston Astros
are gonna steal
other teams' Purell.
That's what we're hearing.
[ Laughter ]
-Indeed.
-Everyone is talking about
the coronavirus, but healt
officials are telling everyone
to stay calm.
This weekend,
the Surgeon General
praised President Trump's
response
and even said that Trump
is healthier than he is.
[ Laughter ]
Can we see the Surgeon General
Can we see Trump?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That looks
like a personal trainer
and his client
who keeps canceling.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's just...
"Can't make it.
Sorry, can't make it today."
[ Laughter ]
"Very busy. Very busy."
-"Gotta golf."
-"I'm going through a tunnel
sorry."
[ Laughter ]
This weekend, Trump was aske
if a final decision
had been made about
the docking of a cruise ship
with positive
coronavirus cases on board
Check out his response.
-Docking to the ship.
Has a decision been made?
-Uh...
That's a very good question.
[ Laughter ]
-Great. That's what we nee
in times of crisis --
a cliffhanger, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Looks like someone just aske
him the ages of his kids.
"Uh..."
[ Laughter ]
"18? 9?
I don't..."
[ Laughter ]
"20?"
Meanwhile, Senator Ted Cru
was exposed to the coronavirus
and is now in self-quarantine.
And once again, we've learne
it's never good when the words
"coronavirus" and "Cruz"
are in the same sentence.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Never good.
-Come on.
-And now experts are warning
people over 70
from traveling or gatherin
in large crowds.
In other words,
the 2020 presidential election
is cancelled.
I'm sorry.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
They can't...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-On Sunday, Bernie Sanders sai
that he won't cancel rallies
or other campaign events
because of the coronavirus
Bernie was like,
"If the bubonic plague
didn't take me out,
nothing will."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Bubonic plague?
All right,
let's change the subject
to something more upbeat.
Today, the stock market suffered
its worse loss since 2008.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the stock market
dropped almost 2,000 points.
It's times like these I wish
Bloomberg was still in the rac
'cause you know he would'v
taken out his wallet
and said,
"How much do you need?"
[ Laughter ]
But get this --
as the stock market tanked
this morning, Trump tweeted,
"Good for the consumer.
Gasoline prices coming down.
[ Light laughter ]
That's like the Titanic sinkin
and the captain yelling,
"Good news -- free deck chairs."
[ Laughter ]
"Take as much as you want.
Don't worry about it.
Free! Free!
Take five. Sure.
I don't care."
[ Applause ]
The primaries are still going,
and Bernie Sanders
has been criticizing Joe Biden
for his ties
to the corporate establishment
He may have a point,
because a lot of big companies
have been endorsing Biden, but
they all had different reasons
For example, Chipotle said
"Just like our burritos,
we like that
he's great in the beginnin
and falls apart at the end."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Next up, Powerade said, "We're
everyone's second choice, too.
Don't worry about it."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You don't have Gatorade?"
And finally, TikTok said,
"We're committed to endorsin
the younger candidate."
So there you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
77 years old.
Well, this weekend,
President Trump fired
his third chief of staff
Mick Mulvaney.
Then he assigned him
to a new job --
special envoy
to Northern Ireland.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Seems like Trump's kind of
punishing Mulvaney.
Just look at some of
the other jobs
Trump thought about giving him
First, there was ambassado
to North Korea.
[ Laughter ]
Next up, the activities director
on a Princess cruise ship.
[ Laughter ]
Then, there was,
Apple Store employee
that exclusively handles
customers 75 and up.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"This said my name."
[ Laughter ]
-"It's glad."
-And finally, an Uber driver
on St. Patrick's Day.
-I mean, that's --
You don't want these things.
These aren't very good gigs, no.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The news can sometimes
be pretty heavy,
so I thought maybe I'd take
second to focus in a poetic wa
on some of the news storie
that you might have missed
that are a big lighter.
These are real news stories.
You'll see what I mean.
It's time for "In Lighter News."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪ In Lighter News ♪♪
-Roses are red.
Violets grow wide.
Drunk Uber rider
taken for a $1,700 ride.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Roses are red.
Violets go in a bonnet.
Two men arrested for
the possession of whale vomit.
[ Laughter ]
Roses are red.
Violets have chemicals.
We now know how millipedes hav
sex thanks to glowing genitals
[ Laughter and applause ]
Roses are red.
Violets are their neighbor
Newspaper prints extra pages for
people to use as toilet paper.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪ In Lighter News ♪♪
- Real.
Real news. Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-And, finally, check this out.
Just in time for Easter,
Crocs is teaming up with Peeps
to offer a special shoe.
Take a look at this.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
Peeps and Crocs.
Just paint the word "moist
and you'd have a trifecta
of things people hate.
We have a great show.